joining us right now in the same way
everyone's getting a podcast we were way
ahead of the game chris i'll be very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very
honestly
michael irvin joined us yesterday to
promote his new podcast
this guy's got a new podcast with his
former teammate and lifelong friend
uh mark ingram of the ravens cameron
jordan
and mark ingram are launching their
newest original podcast
trust levels now again
uh we all know about trust trust big
trust right
and the levels are spelled with a z oh
okay does everyone understand
when you're looking for it trust levels
nice artwork right there
cameron jordan of the new orleans saints
the co-host of trust levels
is back here on the show how are you bud
uh you know i i'd like to say i'm doing
great but i feel like i could be better
um how would you be sitting at 3-0 i've
been really great uh we've got to you
know we got to get these wins in
before i get to your team and your pod
what do you think of hearing
when what do you think of when you hear
that the titans are dealing with the
first what appears to be covet 19
significant amounts of positive tests
what are you going what's going through
your mind
cameron uh first off you know i hope
it has been said that if anyone has a
positive positive i mean there's false
positives or whatever in this world
um i'm hoping that nobody actually has
coven 19 and everybody's
uh filthy and safe and at the same time
i feel like you know the nfl will put
them through the protocols to get
everybody back on track
um as i've as i've heard but the vikings
and titans
won't be in building till saturday
something that you know we
we as a as a football player we as a
team or whatever
have to be always aware of our
situations within coles at 19
and really just have to stay focused and
vigilant on doing our best efforts of
not trying to
have too many outside variables so um
but you
you do you feel safe based on the
protocols that have been set up for you
by the league and the players
association or does this give you a
pause here
cameron uh i didn't hear that last part
you said yeah i mean
all i know is when it comes down to it
you know at least the saints have been
have been doing the uh have been clear
of it
um and if we have to come across that
bridge we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to deal with it accordingly
um i can only uh again i can only give
the best wishes to to both the teams
dealing with this right now yeah
absolutely
and just for those who may be curious
um and i'm one of them then you count me
in there
how quickly after a game are you tested
walk us through the testing process for
you as a player
cameron jordan uh would say whatever
that is the next morning
um even you know even when we had stayed
in
in vegas we got tested the next morning
so morning after
and i mean you probably get those i'm
not sure how fast you get those results
but it's
it's still you know you go can you come
in the building and you're still looking
around like i hope everybody's okay you
know this this is our new norm
and this is something that you know
we've dealt with now at least three
weeks
all the teams in the league and for this
to pop up is something that you know
sort of scares you a little bit at the
same time
this is one of the risks that you knew
coming into the season right and then
and then when's the last time before a
game that you're tested
great question saturday 24 hours before
okay whatever whatever the league man it
is i mean we we go
we're pretty pretty standard in how we
follow our procedures
um i'm pretty sure it's 20 24 hours
before i believe something like that
okay cameron jordan here on the rich
eisen show now let's get to your team
and i want uh trust levels answers if
you don't mind cameron
all right um what do you make of the
narrative
that is gaining more and more steam each
week
that your quarterback is showing
diminishing returns of being somebody
over the age of 40. what do you make of
that
conversation cameron uh i'd like to say
he was his most accurate last year when
the same narrative was around
um and the most accurate he's been in
his career i mean
we're talking about three games in i
feel like i'm putting everything on
defense more than i would put on
uh offense who just put up 30 points on
the board
um this is something that you know us as
a team has to get better from this is
something that
you know we we've been sort of
self-inflicted a lot of our
pains and our own wounds from penalties
on ourselves
after we clean that up i mean when you
have 70 and you know 70 to 100 yards
worth of penalties
especially on on crucial uh downs this
is something that you have to clean up
and have to get better from
now but you also know being somebody uh
who goes and hunts quarterbacks for a
living cameron jordan and watches
film and circles people on film
does your quarterback look like someone
to you who can't get it down the field
vertically
um i think we just had a 50 yard
touchdown last week
um from ak but that being said down the
field
um absolutely not i mean he looks like a
quarterback who still makes all the
right all the throws and still able to
make explosive habits and
you know when mike t comes back that'll
be another piece of offense that is just
explosive is
at one of the most premiere positions
you can have um
i if anything i'd say i trust i trust
drew more and more
every time that he's ever taken the
field than i would in by any other
quarterback now
uh cameron uh the the um
the the pass to your running back was
like one yard and he ran at 70. so i
mean you know i gotta i gotta i gotta
keep it trust levels too whenever i talk
to you
um but that said i'm i'm not one of
these people that's
uh burying your quarterback i want that
said before i
i ask you this is drew pissed about it
he hears it he's got to know it he's got
it he's got to hear it he hears the
insinuating questions when he's asked
does he piss he's been asked those
questions
and however he answers them i mean his
work ethic and the way he takes the
practice and where he takes the games
every
every week uh again it's not for lack of
points if anything i put it on
i put it on defense and how we're able
uh how we should be able to stop some of
these offenses
um once we control you know
our own destiny i feel like that's take
care of itself there's always going to
be naysayers as soon as you know
somebody reaches they were saying you
know
the same thing game one and after we
after we won the game they sort of
quieted down
with every loss there's going to be
always an open
airway at least for for criticism how do
you clean that up then
how does that get cleaned up cameron win
more rich
we have to win this week that's as
simple as that
win i love it
well then what's the challenge this week
i'm sure you're going to start watching
on film
the way that the lions you know perform
their business
obviously kyla murray is a different
quarterback than drew brees but they
were able to pick him off
three times and then you saw what they
were able to do
offensively and not pretty much get off
the field in the fourth quarter what's
the challenge here for you with the
lions this week sir
right i mean they have they have a ton
of weapons um you talk about adrian
peterson and the way
you know we all know h peterson can be
explosive and the way he comes downhill
uh you know they have uh kenny gallaudet
and then of course you've got marvin
jones out there making strong plays
uh from especially from the film we just
watched and you know we
have playmakers everywhere again it's
got to be on our defense i'm looking at
us as a defense to to try and
uh not only affect the affect the
quarterback i mean we can get a couple
early hits and i'm gonna stay that
constant pressure
that's gonna be the game changer before
i ever look at the offense i always look
at our defense and we have to do more
well look man i know when you're
promoting something uh in this world
it's much easier to do it coming off a
win
and uh certainly not two losses so you
know the fact that you're on here
you know is a testament to the fact that
you always spit truth and you're always
a professional and you're always a good
guy
um and that's what i imagine you're br
you and uh and um
ingram are bringing to this podcast what
what
your first guest was uh camara right is
that your first guest
alvin alvin was your first guest correct
yeah big explosive you know straight
from you know alabama to
uh to through his ascension to the
league mm-hmm so now what do you what
are what are people going to get from
this pod
cameron like pound the table for trust
levels pounded
you know some if the first episode is
indica
indicative of anything it's that you
know it's me and one of my you know best
friends
out here having a blast i mean it's me
and mark ingram really just talking
football talking
you know the ascension of some guys that
are coming through and just the path
of how it might not be the most natural
way to get
get to one of these you know big time
schools or get to the league and really
having a fun time doing it i mean you're
catching stories that you may not catch
anywhere else because we have
you know the ability to talk not only
football but just the
uh the pathways and how we all got to
the league yeah i mean the uh
the guests that you have include lamar
jackson kittle camaro obviously derek
henry evans
bobby bobby wagner i love and more um
who who's a guest that you want that's a
question i get a lot
uh cameron who's the guest that you want
that you haven't
i don't know i mean i feel like i i feel
like you sort of gotta i've got a heck
of a start of the list
right now um you know after
i like to say after we we get everything
said and done
i guess that i want i feel like we i
feel like we had everybody the first
season
we're gonna add more on i mean if
anything we just had a lack of episodes
to get it done
okay um so i mean uh
then let me let me put a finer point on
it then uh
which uh sports broadcasting uh guest
do you want the most cameron oh oh yeah
sportscast yeah yeah between between you
uh you know if i get rich eisen on that
thing uh that could that could be a fun
time
you know we bring in uh maybe like
jamil hill uh just cause i used to
always love her her podcast sure
um shannon sharp i mean this is
all the all the bright personalities of
the world is only gonna make a podcast
even more fun
yeah you should have stopped you'd be
and i love jamil and obviously shannon
can tell
so many stories there's no between me
and anyone else i mean like there's just
one
camera honestly obviously think about
this if i could get me
yeah you yeah with mark ingrams
and then we bring in like colin cowherd
oh sure
we could have debates for days
except i believe what i say
[Laughter]
you know every big trust level that's
what i'm saying i mean
when because if you know for those who
may not understand trust levels means
you
you're spitting truth and you believe
what you say you back it up right and
that you
right you you're spitting your truth and
if you can back up your truth then it
could be a truth to be backed up on
thank you
very good cameron i really appreciate
your calls congrats on the pod
uh new episodes released every wednesday
the uh premiere episode released last
week with the
alvin kamara best of luck stay healthy
stay safe
cameron you and your family okay
absolutely as my dog mark would say big
trust
that's right as all 87 sacks that i've
had in my career thus far it's always
levels to this
that's so you knew that number off the
top of your head i know i mean
look i'm on a hunt i'm on a mission this
year we just got to get more wins and it
starts with the defense
you know what if i said to you hey in
terms of you know pass rushers that i
want to have on this show
that i want between you and and then
finish the sentence with other people
who are
you know respected um but i just how
would you feel
uh like i'd be in a very respectable
company okay
all right maybe i need to look in the
mirror is what you're saying cameron
jordan i got it look if you said hey i i
want you
and chandler jones on the on on show i'm
like dope
you know uh there's no there's nobody
who i enjoy more than watching other
past rushers
okay so if you say you know chandler
jones or if you say julius peppers or
you know you say justin houston or
robert quinn or jj white i mean there's
all right
all right i get it now i feel like crap
cameron thank you my gosh
[Laughter]
congrats again on the pod b wells be
safe much appreciate it take care
right back at you that's cameron jordan
at cam jordan94
trusts levels